woohoo
yay theories of everything
with kurt try mongol welcome i mean
thank you
[Laughter]
so used to being the host
[Laughter]
i love it how are you doing man
so good so did you just come from
meditating
life is a meditation my brother did you
just
explicitly meditate like close your eyes
and stay still for
a couple minutes or no
that
is what that usually
is what leads up to meditation
being what you are so usually you
go and practice meditation
in order for you to end up having like a
contemplative fitness ai that's
perpetually running
in a sense so you no longer need to go
and
separately meditate it just becomes what
you are
perpetually and so i feel like i've just
recently
sort of made that transition as well
where
you the the amount of sovereignty that
you end up having the supreme authority
over what used to be like this big web
of conditioning
and triggers and sensory perception
you gain so much sovereignty because
you're able to watch
the arising and passing of phenomena and
it's just regaining that awareness
and it's so beautiful so yeah
yeah i don't agree with these spiritual
teachers who
have been meditating for years and
continue to do so you think that they
should
be moved past that
well one of the ways that buddha talked
about this
is as an undistracted non-meditation
so undistracted so you're not fixating
and it's a non-meditation because you're
not
meditating it's just an undistracted
perpetual thought-free wakefulness
does that make sense i understand okay
yeah yeah yeah so i feel like when
when you're not going straight to the
end goal of thought-free wakefulness
then you're almost perpetuating yourself
to need to sit on the cushion
more and more so work your way into a
place
where you can experience a
contemplative fitness ai that's
basically running in the background
where just
nothing can trigger you nothing
can and but we're always working on
basically deconditioning ourselves
that's what the the art is um in many
ways
yeah forgive my petty fogging nature
but what do you mean by contemplative
fitness ai what's meant by the word
fitness in there
[Laughter]
he's already taken the interview over i
love you
oh well just for the audience yes yes i
don't know how many people are watching
but for the people who are watching
i'm much more comfortable as an
interviewer than an interviewee
i feel like i my predominant position on
most topics is just i don't know
i'm just cerebrate in most places and
that includes math and physics which is
my background
so i don't know i imagine that much of
what you'll get is
extreme uncertainty and dubiousness for
myself
you know what's fascinating and we can
put a little flag in this
in the fitness in contemplative fitness
ai and potentially circle back to that
because cool
because i feel like where kurt and i
have so much overlap because this will
probably end up being
more of a conversation is that
since 2017
i had this list of all of these insanely
thought-provoking questions about the
nature of reality
and then the number one thing that came
up was how do i go and ask the smartest
people that i have access to
all of these thought provoking questions
about what the nature of reality is
and in a sense would you say that that's
what you're doing
what i'm trying to do is understand the
landscape of theories of everything
which involves speaking to some experts
in some sense the idea behind the theory
of everything is
synonymous with what is the nature of
reality so in that respect yes
although although i'm not particularly
focused on speaking to
people like these kanye shentis i'm
mainly interested in
the theories and they're an avenue to
not only
an income source of mind so there's
obviously a monetary element to it
though in the beginning there's nothing
and even still it's not like it's
it's paying all the bills but there's
obviously that
there's obviously some making a name for
myself but there's also
there's i don't
there's so many questions i have and i
wanted to title
the youtube channel office hours because
i come from an academic background
and in academia what you have are office
hours a professor
starts let's say wednesdays from four to
eight and you can go talk to them about
about your homework about whatever
questions come to mind so for me
i treat it more like office hours i
office hours that i film and that's the
predominant quality
[Applause]
so there's both this theories of
everything that
end up being a
landscape of how self-awareness
perceives the nature of its reality
and then creating some sort of a
a map about what
is in that landscape across the planet
of what people think
the point of all of this is and then
another part of it is
it's like office hours regarding getting
these brilliant people
on and then having them
answer these questions that are
not only about adding them to the
theories of everything
landscape map but also about
poking and prodding and getting
new insights one of the most important
things that i've noticed from
the guests that come on the show is and
you've actually filmed this and included
them in your intro several times
is when your guests have said you know
kurt
this has been one of my best interviews
and that's because of your poking and
pro
and prodding and enabling
it's like tennis where you're enabling
them to further
increase their insights around their own
ideas
yeah yes well
that's a huge compliment like i
i i do my best to prepare
i prepare like mad like met like you
wouldn't believe
like it drains me how much i prepare
so when they say that it shows which i'm
always
insecure about if any of it shows not
that i'm trying to have it show
but it would be great if even a modicum
of it showed i it's great that some of
that's exuded
and that they acknowledge it
your essence reminds me a little bit of
jordan peterson
yeah i get the i get i i used to get
that more
one of the reasons
seems to be that i'm ex i'm extremely
careful with what i say
i'm trying to make sure that what i'm
saying is my
own word and that it's not
that it's not unfairly adopted from
someone else without my
conscious effort trying to make it my
own
and then another reason is obvious is
that i've watched plenty of him and i
don't know how to stop someone
that i've seen from influencing my life
on a
micro level for example there's also
tony robbins in me
because i used to watch plenty of tony
robbins when i did stand up it was
like seinfeld and colin quinn because
those are my favorite ones and it's not
like i'm trying to copy them
it's just that there's no way for me to
export them completely
and this might be
quite specific to today's interaction
i've noticed it a little bit across your
other interviews but i've also noticed
different emanations of of what your
unique expression
is but
there seems to be and correct me if i'm
wrong
or just expand on this for us but have
you
felt
sort of your own sense of identity burst
outside of your skin
yeah yeah and walk us through that yeah
it usually happens around the one hour
mark in an interview
it's mainly when i get comfortable with
myself so right now
i'm somewhat habitudinous because i
haven't slept for
oh i have slept but i have slept poorly
for the past five days or so
and usually once i'm in the flow that's
when it comes out
not that i'm not in the flow man like i
respect and love you
it just takes a while and i just came
off from a previous podcast so that one
somewhat exhausted me and i have another
one right after this
and then i got to like sleep in a in a
river of
opium not just a joke but like just like
completely
bathe myself in
in silk and satin
and just go to sleep for like 12 hours
yeah that was one of the things that we
were talking about before we went on was
just
respectfully
yourself for being able to actually
actualize this channel at its fullest
potential
because sometimes what we think is doing
all the sessions and this was my case
also especially in 2018 and 2019 was
doing
um even at these conferences like ten
shows in a day
um like ten one to two hour shows in a
day
um and that was [ __ ] crazy uh
and that and that type of energy is cool
and it has its place
but um but
there's also the energy for the
rejuvenation
but just to play on this question a
little bit more you know you've had
people like rupert spyra on the show and
you've had
these more
mystically literate via direct
experience
when people like rupert tell you that
you are god you've just forgotten that
you are
god does that resonate with you
um it does in some sense and it does
doesn't in another so i think if i
had had that realization it would
rock me to my core
in some sense i can intellectually
understand it but that's the issue
that's another reason why okay let's
let's play on this a little bit
so you have
awareness is that right
okay so would you say that
the the mind
is kind of like magic
i don't know what you mean by that like
are you blown away
by the fact that you have the power to
know
yes but just stay with that feeling a
little bit more
right
okay okay
where is this going
we'll see so
this power to know
equality that's
enabling your perception
right now
would would would you say that it's
possible that we're
habitually overlooking the profundity of
consciousness
you know there's something wittgenstein
said and i like i know i quote him
perhaps a bit too much but he had
something called clarificatory remarks
which is which are those aspects of
reality that are
most important but hidden because of
their synthetic familiarity
exactly wittgenstein gets taken as the
as the paragon of a rational atheist but
actually
he was profoundly deeply religious and
many people don't
realize that the reason why he didn't
speak much about religion was because he
had a quote which said
there of what one cannot speak of
precisely one must be silent
and he had extreme religious veneration
as he got older to the point where
i think his close friend norman malcolm
said that
the religiosity that characterized
wittgenstein was greater than that of
people who consider themselves to be
religious
beautiful so you resonate with
the notion that we might be
perpetually habitually overlooking
what is so profound which is the fact
that we have
the quality of the power to know
consciousness well i don't know if
that's what's the most profound i know
it's
somewhat profound i don't know if it's
the most so there's another call
somewhat for fun there's another there's
a great idea from
there's a great idea that the kingdom of
god lays before men but men do not see
it
yes yes
see you remind me and i mention this to
you but you remind me so much of
me especially like
right before like six months ago where
like this realization rupert was one of
the most
important people in in catalyzing this
realization
basically what i see you doing which is
what i was doing
which is the eyeballs are faced
outward and they're they're scraping the
landscape
of the nature of reality looking for who
are the people that know the most
physics and that know the most math and
that know the most about these different
fields
neuroscience philosophy how can i
take in how can i sponge in what the
peaks
of these landscapes know and you know
take in all this information and refract
it
uniquely into a theory of of everything
well you may not be doing that that last
part necessarily but it does feel like
you are uh to an extent but then what
the
key switch is is when rather than the
eyeballs
being protruded outward trying to find
the nature of reality
the eyeball turns on itself
bloodborne wait what what is this have
you played bloodborne
it's a hidey hidotaki miyazaki game
dark souls have you heard of dark oh
dark souls yes yes we had a game called
bloodborne
and in it the characters who
had true insight were in they would turn
their eyes inside out
and put many eyes pointed toward the end
kurt you have the
answer it's it's right under your nose
you're pointing to it in different ways
from wicked stein to this
dark souls you're pointing at it in so
many different ways
truly you are you know that this is both
yeah well what's the answer
you are it you
are it
okay i don't understand what that means
alan like
you are the nature of reality like
you you are the highest
okay now how does now what does that
mean because i imagine if one is saying
you referring to me then one can say
that you referring to anyone
and thus they're that's it's all the
highest which also means it's all the
lowest
which means it's all the same which is
the same as non-dualism
which to me i don't see how i go
i have quite a few problems with
non-dualism though i skirt with it
one of them is i don't see it as
anything i don't see it i don't see how
it's not veiled nihilism
let's play with direct experience a
little bit more so
you have your conscious
and that
would you say that consciousness is
less would you say that the quality of
the power to know
you know how water is wet
and like wet wetness is like a quality
wetness is like a formless quality
okay okay and then like kind of like
sweetness
right sweetness is like a property one
can say this property or no
let's play with quality for now equality
and so now you have the power to know
which is also like a formless quality
so so rather than the fixation
externally on
form name and shape the eyeball has
turned
inward on itself
and is now recognizing that this
consciousness awareness
the power to know is something so
profound
and so indescribable so
formless that it's been overlooking
and now what you see is kurt might it be
possible
that if you look at consciousness
without any attributes
so what does it look like to be
consciousness without
the costume of kurt or consciousness
without the costume of rupert
or without the costume yeah i understand
oh that does make sense yes okay so now
now you see that that consciousness
without its costumes
so when you look at it most upstream as
just the formless power to know
that is what people are pointing at for
the last millennia
when they talk about the kingdom of god
is within you
that this is the highest the absolute
appearing
for an exploration of infinite
possibility i understand okay and so
what
what holds you back is it like logic and
reasoning or what is the thing that kind
of like holds you back
from recognizing that this is the
highest coming to
explore a possibility of infinity
well like i said if it's the highest
it's also the lowest
and so does one want to say that
that this is the lowest and if one is
not going to say it's the lowest then
why is
why is it high and not low no it's
beautiful so
we see that today when we look at people
not having their basic needs being met
and
where we have uh war where we have war
and where we have
famine and where we have all of the
worst catastrophic
issues they're happening here on the
same planet that
the absolute most ecstatic
god realization is happening so it's all
happening here
this is all it yeah so so we're not
necessarily even trying to create a
um adjustment you're cutting off and i
want to make sure i'm
hearing every single word do you mind
repeating it yeah of course
so we see the this manifestation of play
like what we're talking about
is both hold on hold on
we still have a manifestation of play
okay yes yes
and then that there's
it's both exploring the
archetypal hell at the same time as
there is the exploration of the
archetypal heaven
hold on alan please i want to make sure
can people can you double check if the
chat can hear you or if it's just me
that's cutting
that's hearing you cut in and out
people are watching can you hear alan
completely and clearly
without break
oh we love you brando thanks for your
love
oh ah okay so it's just myself
all right well sorry continue
okay well let's see if can you hear me
now
curry that's my headphones i apologize
man no worries
no worries we're going through all of
the lovely we love you guys we love
thank you for your love
it also may be that i have obs running
in the background sometimes that messes
it up
okay do you mind speaking speaking hello
yes we are testing
testing for kurt you guys are you guys
are so kind look at all these lovely
comments
thank you thank you everyone okay okay
okay all right
let's get back to this so you were
saying okay cool do you see all these
lovely comments
kurt yeah man they're only positive it's
just plaudits and i appreciate it well
because people love your channel and
and they love what we've been doing on
ours as well and so it's a it's a
beautiful colliding
and um cool so you did you hear that
last sentence pretty clearly
no oh you still didn't no no repeat it
please
oh i mean the last the very recent one
that i just said yeah
oh this is clear yeah okay great great
okay so
that if we if we play
from the perspective of an
an infinite amount of possibility
and we we are that
which explores that
infinite possibility okay okay and so
then
we use these realities
and consciousness as the mechanism
to explore infinite potential
are you still following
and that these realities have the
archetype that you just described
which is the absolute hellishness as
well as the absolute heaven
simultaneously so you have
tanks and murder
and hanging people and famine
at the same time that you have ecstasy
and yachts and jet packs
and thanksgiving dinners
what privilege is one over the other
what privileges one over the other
meaning
like why would why would you get to do
one of those and somebody else does
another one
like why would should one be pursued and
the other not
so why should one not go around raping
and pillaging and murdering and
tormenting and
causing anguish on a local or global
level
yeah that's a great question so
you intrinsically you know the answer to
that question
like every one of us intrinsically knows
the answer that question
because if you go back to what we've
started with which was that we share
the power to know we share consciousness
we share that same
if you get there what happens is and you
can also see that externally you're like
yeah all the species share the same
planet
so you can also see it externally at the
same time that you recognize that you
actually
create harm to yourself
to your own home when you rape and
pillage
and do any of those horrible negative
activities
but that's part of the exploration it's
part of the play
but so the more that you get the you
know the most metaphysical level like
you just had chris langan on the show we
were talking about that a little bit
before we started but
when you take it from the most
metaphysical level which is out of an
infinite amount of possibility because
when you truly grok
infinity you begin recognizing that
an infinite amount of possibility you
can never come to the end of exploring
and this is basically what kirk girdle
and
and douglas hofstetter and
donald hoffman are talking about as well
is that you you can't actually
come to the
truth that you are a playstation 5
playing infinite games but you can't
come to that truth from within grand
theft auto
so you're trying to find the truth that
you're in playstation 5 playing infinite
games but you're trying to find it from
within gta
okay so when people bring up kurt gertle
i i want to know what's the relationship
between a first order language and
our physical reality or this reality
because
what kurt gerdel was saying was
extremely specific it was with
any axiomatic system strong enough to
produce some
qualities like arithmetic and so on so
what's the relationship between that
what's to say that
reality has anything to do with that it
also is an extremely computational view
of reality and i don't think
reality is necessarily computational
that's all that's penrose's entire
argument
is that okay let's substitute the word
computational with comprehensive
are you comprehending reality right now
if what you mean is do i comprehend some
aspects of reality like in my
understanding
well i would say i think i understand
some things
is the fundamental nature of
consciousness to comprehend
no why
you think it is
i would say the fundamental
quality of consciousness is awareness
but but that also is just a tautology
because it seems like
you're substituting one word for
synonyms
so then would the fundamental nature of
awareness be to comprehend
what do you okay you have to explain to
me what you mean by comprehend
you see this is where i'm saying there's
like a bit of that of
like when you sort of like relax
i know i'm not being as mega mystic in
the least i
know i know i love you it's i i sense
this though i
sense it in your essence like there's
like this
like give me the you know this
definition of
comprehend but you know i know you know
intrinsically like what just like you
said earlier well why won't somebody
just go
and create violence and havoc and
you know the answer i okay object to
that
okay because there are obviously people
who are driven by that who think that
that is the highest good and the example
that i give
frequently is 1206 with genghis khan of
course he said
where he said that the highest good is
to put my enemies heads on a stick and
rape their
women and that was the good to him so
it's not exactly obvious and
see this is what i see the new age
community being driven by this
paulianic view of what humans are but
plenty of people are motivated by it
by pointing down they have a god and
it's
down and i don't i don't see the
recognition of that
in in these in some of these
non-dualist circles so how old is how
old is genghis khan again a thousand
years old
almost 1200 approximately is when he had
his reign
okay so a thousand years ago
where was our level of self-awareness
compared to now
that's another way to view that question
because if you look at the level of
self-awareness a thousand years ago
that was more of the essence where you
could sort of
say that i want to put my enemies heads
on sticks
and i want to rape the women and today
in modernity with 8 billion people in
the internet and computers
and we see the planet as one organism
and we see
the these conscious agents aka humans
as this shared computational
or comprehensive unit
that then is what is exploring
so in a sense you can't get away with
that anymore
self-awareness has increased to the
point where
you can no longer get away with
having this drastic level of malevolence
and uh and violence
okay well what you're saying man it's so
embedded in assumptions upon assumptions
that
so here's one it's a highly contested
issue whether or not we've progressed in
any moral
respect from one thousand or two
thousand years ago
and many in some people some people
would say we've lost our way especially
since
uh for vicky would say since the
invention of vowels which sounds like
has absolutely nothing to do with this
but
that was around the year 1200 as well or
at least the invention of
literacy which was around
sorry written word which is currently
thousand i believe minus
kurt kurt
if if you can get to the understanding
that this
is the same intelligence talking to
itself
can can you get to that understanding
the same intelligence look
you mentioned that you don't
particularly like my persnickety
adherence to
but but the reason is that
you mentioned girdle well why do you
mention girdles see this is what i see
the
i don't mean this is any demeaning
quality to the spiritual or new age
community i just have no other word for
for that community than like that and i
have almost
utmost respect otherwise i wouldn't have
interviewed people like bernardo castro
and spyra and so on and so on and in
fact i tend to primarily interview
those people because they think contrary
to me
my i see people
i see them as being as being motivated
and not knowing that they're motivated
so for example they'll mention girdle or
they'll mention that the universe looks
at a certain scale to look to have the
same connections as
neuronal connections
okay well how did girdle get how does
that get to
isn't it just trying to share with you
what is right under your
nose isn't that just trying to share
with you what's right under its nose
when i'm asking for specificity
it's the same process that girdle did in
order to
show that set theory as
we had it well it's actually even more
profound than said theory
but whatever that a formal system that
has certain qualities
has truths when it's within it that one
can't prove within okay whatever
whatever
that was from a deep investigation into
the details
and the reason why i i pin you down or
i'm carping
it's not because i i'm trying to prove
you wrong in any way shape or form it's
because
i'm trying to understand and i know as
someone who's
studied some topics like mathematics and
physics
ex and and philosophy extremely deeply
that
much of what we think makes sense on the
surface upon closer investigation falls
apart
it's like you're fighting a ghost and
you don't realize it until you
investigate it at its extremes until you
until you want to know well what do you
precisely mean by so and so and so and
so
and and thus i'm not being unfairly
captured
i'm trying to get to the essence i i
also know that what can
seem like it makes sense on the surfaces
is misleading when tackled from a
different angle
so arguments are enthemic meaning that
they have embedded in them
unstated assumptions and that they take
an inordinate amount of time to
decompress or to uncompress sorry and
thus if you ask me well does your
awareness is your awareness like you ask
me a simple question is awareness aware
of awareness
okay it seems like it is yes okay kurt
why don't you just say it is
because i don't know if it is
i see it i see it seeming like it is
in this moment but give me enough time
and they're an accounting competition
may emerge
or counter feeling i'm not gonna just
sit here and accept what i don't
what i don't feel is irreplicable
i'm gonna attack it or at least i don't
have to attack it it just comes up and
i'm presenting
the i'm presenting what
appears in my mind so please don't think
of me as being
i don't want you to think i'm being
unfair to you i'm i respect and i love
you
but you know what's going through my
mind yeah thank you
yeah it's so beautiful it's a dialectic
it's
really truly just a dialectic and
when i when i feel into where you're
coming from right now
i very much sense a lot of
a lot of scientific a lot of
a lot of logic and a lot of proof
like i want proof proof proof and
but the proof the most in a sense truest
proof is your direct experience
above all else as in when you
become aware that this is one
intelligence talking to itself
so it becomes more transpersonal you've
heard that word
right thrown around before on the shows
and in conversation
does this make does this make sense like
it becomes more transpersonal like the
whole
game of the universe becomes more
transpersonal
like the the curt boundary the boundary
becomes perforated does that make sense
okay yep cool okay and so then it
becomes your direct experience
that the boundary has become perforated
so you went from what is more of like a
centralized
connectome neuroscientifically
to what is more of like a decentralized
connectome or a universalized
connectome where you now see that this
is one intelligence talking to itself
in an explorative way exploring one of
endless possibility through this
earth orbiting the star and there's many
other earth's orbiting stars
and that there's many other potential
universes
where there are other earth's orbiting
stars with other conscious agents that
are exploring possibility
right he's sort of following that train
a little bit okay so we consider them to
be
let's get down into the details of this
particular statement do you
consider there to be other universes or
is the fact that it exists and the
criteria for
it to be in the universe meaning it
exists imply that there's only one
universe
so that is why don't you just call the
collection of them universe so if there
are two universes the collection is the
universe
it's just let's say subset of the
universe two subsets so
i'm curious in your like in the
definition of
universe does yours include all that
there is to reality
because if that's what it means then
there can't be multiple universes
well just remember that universe means
one song
and so the universe says or
the multiverse or the meta verse would
mean many songs
potentially up to infinite songs
and so when you begin viewing creation
this universe as one song
you begin seeing that the amount of
possible songs
is endless you'll never come to the end
of different ways that you can arrange
musical notes into songs
and currently if we if we also stay with
the perforation
let's get back to that yeah the solution
of the boundaries
beautiful so i know that you know and
it's so
beautiful because i know you know and
that because you've been
searching you've been searching for as
rumi says you've been looking from room
to room
for the diamond that is already around
your neck
and six months ago boom i went into a
nervous system shock when i finally got
what roomie meant
can you explain what you mean by nervous
system shock what happened to you
well just like 10 minutes of just curled
over in the fetal position because i
finally got
it which is i am it we are
it exploring
okay here's a counter proposition
given that the mind is self-deceptive
how do you know that that's not a
deception
given that plenty of what we experience
is said to be an illusion well how do
you know what you just
experienced is not just another illusion
free will is an experience by the way
but free will is
also said to be an illusion so how do
you know that this
insight is a reflection of reality
rather than
the deceptive quality of one's own mind
simply because you feel it extremely
deeply to be true
is that the criteria because if that is
the criteria well there's plenty of
contradictory deeply felt theories and
truths
i i hope you don't feel like i'm
attacking you man not at all i love you
by the way i also want to say that this
conversation i feel like is
one of the best ways for
the internet for all of us to undergo
a process of understanding what the
nature of reality is
and so i'm feeling a really strong
brotherhood between us
where we can potentially continue doing
this maybe once a quarter or something
where we're just revisiting where we're
at in this process of
podcast therapy yeah it's like well
inflorescence just on the blooming of a
flower
yes by time yes and look at how many
people were in the comments saying that
we love you both
this is great like this is i do feel
really strong about
this because also kurt what you're doing
in a sense is you're playing
like the question you just asked was so
perfect which is that how do you know
that this mind that is so magical
how do you know that it's uniting with
the nature of reality
and that it's not deceiving you that's a
great question
and so many people want to hear these
styles of
this is basically you know science and
spirituality which we both represent
both
we both represent both this is
them both coming to a union it's us
exploring
the synthesis between science and
spirituality which are the two greatest
driving forces behind our planet
period there's nothing that drives us
more than those two forces
and so to unite them to figure out how
to unite them i feel like
is the 21st century this is what what we
are doing
the century because we're turned inward
and we're analyzing
more and more of the interscape at the
same time that we're meeting
planetary basic needs and we're
maximizing our external architectures
that enable people to self-actualize and
self-realize
and so i i'm feeling a really strong
resonance
between us and so let's let's explore
what you asked
so
i can restate it if you like
i have the question okay
there's so many things okay here here
here okay
it's uniting with the force that made
you
it's a clear uniting with the force that
made you okay
you're giving me an answer do you mind
telling me the question that you're
answering because i want to make sure
we're on the same page
yeah otherwise it's simply a statement
[Music]
yeah
how do how does one know yes
when their mystical experience and again
mysticism just means becoming one with
god
means becoming one with the divine how
does one know
when they're mystical or yoga yoga means
union how does one know when their union
is true versus
delusional okay well
was that the question that's what it no
because in the question you're
you're assuming an answer which is the
mysticism which is the unity with god
and the yoking so i'm saying how do you
know that whatever you see
is true not whether your
insight about sorry not whether or not
the union is true
i'm asking how do you know your felt
experience if what we're taking primary
is experience
all right man let's do it together i
love it yeah we're both on the standing
game now
to relax the lower back yeah it's great
yeah and also
i i need to i'm going to go for a long
walk tomorrow as i mentioned that i
i've been i've been cooped up and
working and i'm looking forward to
having a great rest tonight man
i appreciate this conversation i'm i'm
having a joy talking to you and if you
want to talk for longer to another time
more than welcome to you okay so let me
get back to yeah
which is that it sounds like you are
saying
correct me if i'm wrong but this is also
echoed by people like spyra
which is that experience is primary and
from experience you can derive some
truth since one of these truths are
that we're all one and that all there is
is experience or all there is is
awareness
sometimes awareness being aware of
awareness but awareness nonetheless
and i'm asking
how does one know your experience of
so-and-so
uniting was like a horse that gave rise
to you was my answer to that question
okay you're saying it's true because
it's uniting
it's true because that's good i like
that and then how about also it's true
because
there's an experience of
basically uniting with the
energy that gave rise to you the force
that gave rise to you the force that
gives rise to all life
when people talk about oneness or unity
it's like uniting with that force itself
that gave rise
if we play with the big bang theory it
would be like it would be like uniting
with the force that gave rise to the big
bang
that would be what
okay now let me see if i can correct
that and if this correction is apt
is it more like realizing that you're
uniting
because one cannot help but unite they
can only realize that this uniting is
occurring all the time
they are realizing yeah that's why it's
called self-realization or god
realization
it's a realization what's actualization
mean then
sometimes people say self-actualization
is that a synonym
and if they're different how are they
different i love this beautiful question
so when you view um
self-realization or god realization that
is the turn
inward and uniting with that force that
gave rise to you like we were just
discussing
and then self actualization is more like
the tony robbins
styler like gary vaynerchuk style like
executing a dream like
actualizing your unique firework of life
so it's a little bit more around
empowerment
versus enlightenment but those two are
the same side of the
coin two different sides of the same
coin so self
actualization and self realization are
actually one
so most people when they go outward to
actualize something that's like
what i've noticed is that people from
mainstream society
the first thing that they do is they go
on a hero's journey which is
self-actualization
they usually go into the unknown to try
and
go through some challenges and obstacles
to gain some sort of profound insight
treasure
and then to bring that back to their
community and so it's usually people
leaving the nine to five pursuing
entrepreneurship
stuff like that and then what happens is
they also
undergo a process of the turn inward in
understanding well what is the nature of
of consciousness what is the nature of
my reality
at a deeper level than uh the material
aims that i have and so that's usually
where those two end up
meeting what's why why
do you yeah why do you ask but i also
would like to play with
the perforation a little bit more of
your essence because i feel like
that's where for a moment like we had
something so
unique there which was that you know you
knew
that becoming transpersonal was
key so maybe we play on like what have
been your
experiences with becoming more
perforated or transpersonal
well i've had experiences that
where i've felt as if what i am is a
tentacle in an octopus and that
going back to the source shares me with
everyone though we're all connected and
it's we're temporarily differentiated
but then again i say
i've had that experience and in some
ways i i think
it's true but in some ways i don't take
my experiences or what
is said with agreement in the scientific
or even spiritual community as apodictic
like most people i wonder what's the
alternative
and i'm just not
i'm just not sold i'm just not sold on
it
it could be true but then at the same
time then i wonder even if it is true is
it saying anything that's not
a tautology so for example rupert spires
seems
seems to be saying
something both non-trivially and trivial
at the same time
experiences experience seems to me to be
at the bottom of what he's saying which
is a tautology
so i just i don't know
i love it what a beautiful experience
that you've had
a beautiful realization that you've had
because
in essence that's what science is even
pointing to
in the same way that spirituality has
been pointing to for millennia
which is that there is this there's this
unif you there's this unified
differentiation and then the
differentiation wakes up
to its unification so here's a question
i have for you
yeah how does
fractionation occur from unity
it's beautiful i know it's the most
unbelievably profound thing
um through what we hypothesize one of
the ways we hypothesize this
is um there's a veil of forgetting
that's one of the components that's
really important
so you you know upon differentiation
that there's a veil of forgetting
that has to be pierced through to
remember so it's like hide and seek
you see the archetype in kids and you
see the archetype in animals even
the hide and seek style archetype is
sort of like the game that is being
played
so there's some sort of a veil that has
to be pierced through to remember
this which is there yeah go ahead if
there if there's a reason to forgetting
just like kids playing hide and seek is
there
that also seems to me like that's on
purpose maybe it's dangerous to remember
is there a danger to remembering like
why should we remember even if it's
true perfect exactly this infinite being
is far greater and far
more elucidated than us and it said hey
man you should differentiate and then
we're coming back and saying no we
should unify
and in fact that's the highest good how
do we know it's perfect
i love this this is the exact riddle to
the universe
this is the exact riddle to infinity ex
expressing itself is this
which is that you you purposely
refracted and differentiated to explore
and play why would you pierce through
this veil
and become unified again when the whole
point was to differentiate
and it's a beautiful question and it's
the riddle
because you do both simult
you do both simultaneously where you
pierce through this veil and remember
so you don't create unnecessary
malevolence because you think that
people are separate from the same
unified life force but then while you
pierce through that veil and remember
you also express yourself differently
you don't forget
that kurt is uniquely beautifully
differentiated
than atlas and rupert than donald than
than chris alice or ellen
you can call me atlas yeah yeah it's
okay it's sort of like
is it is this new yeah yeah since
about two years ago one of my friends uh
came
in search results
about about two years ago one of my
friends came came through and was like
you know atlas is is what i feel like is
your name and then only recently about
eight months ago or so
did i make the transition fully to just
one
one word atlas as my name from alan
sakhyan
which some people
yeah officially it's been great bro yeah
it's been great
an atlas has a lot of profound you know
cartography is one of the things that
i'm most interested in right
some sort of cartography around the
nature of reality
that's why we're here together bro
you're literally mapping the landscape
of the theories of everything and i have
the same style of passion
to this and so and we're both young
you're like 30 right
32 32 and i'm 28. we're both right there
bro
that's our little app yep
okay you just said that's the mystery of
the universe
is that well the point is to do both
yes yes because everyone everyone
promulgates
oneness when they they're like people
are awake they're like
it's one planet so there's some people
see it from a physicalism perspective
and they see it like
there's only one planet uh there's 10
million
species they're all there it's like the
gaia thing
everything evolved on the planet so
there's the oneness mentality there and
then there's the people that turn inward
to consciousness
and then they say oneness and they say
unification
and they say that but meanwhile
the whole point of this process
was to differentiate and so then you
have the people that are like hyper
differentiation oriented
and so they're the ones that are like
everyone
actualized their unique firework into
the
arena of reality and so you have to
merge the two the
reason why it's the riddle is because
you have to merge unification and
differentiation
well this to me again is why i see
nondualism as thinly veiled
nihilism because if the point of
existence is to merge what's been
differentiated that's predicated on the
differentiation
and the differentiated people are
considered to be evil which means we
need the evil
which sounds to me like an argument for
not doing good nor evil
because either are okay
yeah just i so i would take one step
back from there and i would say that
um so so differentiation does not
necessarily equate with uh
ignorance or evil and whatnot i i would
yeah i would potentially say that if you
if you can
if you can pierce through the veil and
merge
unification and differentiation
simultaneously
you can have what is like the most um
holistic
understanding of how infinity expresses
itself as
realities um so there's one unified
force but it purposely differentiates
itself
to undergo this play and to pierce
through this veil
to remember itself and then to express
itself
from the place of remembrance do you see
that last
key so if you express yourself from the
place
of solely differentiation you will
not know that you come from the same
unified force
but if you first unite with the unified
force
and then express yourself like a
firework
you'll come from a place of unity as you
differentially
differentially express yourselves and so
that's why
the phrase you gotta go inward first
to go outward right it's the sure cause
of delight
you gotta go inward first to go outward
right
it's the sure cause of delight yeah
but you can go outward from a place of
not going inward first and that's still
just as beautiful at the same time so
because it's the way that infinity's
expressing itself as somebody that
chooses to not go
inward first and they choose to pursue
material
they choose to pursue clout or money
or fame or seeking worthiness or seeking
validation
from other people and so that's also a
unique exploration at the same time
but eventually you're probably familiar
with things like the parable of the
prodigal son
you'll get a nice little sledgehammer
the drill sergeant of awakening
suffering comes with the sledgehammer
and whacks you on the forehead
and it forces you to turn inward because
you don't actually get
any long-term peace and happiness from
acquiring material possessions or
acquiring clout
or fame or trying to extract worthiness
or validation from people
and so the turn inward is almost
inevitable which is part of it's like an
attractor this is where
you might resonate with this it's like
an attractor kurt it's like a
it's a
you have this complex mathematics
that the universe is evolving towards
which is in a sense
life waking up and then turning
inwards to understand itself as the
unified force that differentiated
but you got this you're right there
with my most people i'm sure you would
say are right there anyway
because
it's just it's always with us at least
that's what the claim is
yeah it you can't not be
it's you're into it i still don't see
how
or why an undifferentiated entity
even conceivably can differentiate
because let's say picks a point to do so
that point would have to be
distinguished
but we already said there's no
distinguishing feature so how do you
distinguish without distinguishing
your question is again i feel like it is
literally the most important question in
in the
nature of reality and i feel like one of
the only ways to
artistically be able to express this to
kids is by looking at how
white light refracts prismatically
into the
rainbow gradient because that is
sort of how this looks like where you
have this unified
undifferentiated light that then
refracts
into the prismatic differentiation which
sort of
looks like in a sense the evolution of
awareness or consciousness waking up to
yeah itself that's an argument for
pluralism
to begin with though because if we
investigate that analogy a bit further
the white light was never white
the white light was multitudinous to
begin with
so so if you can give me a different
analogy
that would help
in the white well isn't this the case
that inherent in the white light is the
potentiality for
the diffract the differentiation
no inherent sorry not not don't mean to
say no like so arrogantly but
white light comprises different colors
from the get-go there's no such photon
as a white photon
so if you were to stop any individual
one you could detect its
frequency which is the same as its color
yes the prism doesn't take white light
and then create
multiple different strands it
that's already there in the white light
so that so again i'll ask my question
which is how is it from a place of
non-duality where there is no
you said it's inherent in the s this
source
light right isn't that the kind of the
point is that inherent in
the infinity expressing itself is the
ability to differentiate
and then undergo this creative process
okay what i want to know is how do you
differentiate
where do you differentiate if there is
no difference
so how do you differentiate here over
here is it
random well then is there a random
number generator that's outside the
universe is the random generator
a part of the universe then there's the
universe plus random generator well is
that not a distinguishing
is that not a distinct entity so is so
the universe
is a random number generator at the same
like
that's what i'm saying and then if you
have a random number generator well then
you have obviously differences in digits
which is
not non-dual so this non
this is why i'm this is what i'm
wondering what is
what allows for this differentiation
from
undifferentiated material when that's
all that there is
all there is is on differentiation
yeah that's beautiful beautiful yeah i'm
asking i'm
like genuinely curious i don't know how
how to it's like wearing a circle i
don't understand it i don't know how to
do it
and the same thing is true on my end
which is that
i can't speak to how the
unbounded mystery that we are is
truly being um played
we can only create maps that get close
to the territory
um and so that's what we're doing right
now is we're
talking about maps that try their best
to get as close to
the territory as possible it's almost
like the best thing that the
intelligence can do with itself
is undergo the process of forgetting and
as it remembers
it tries to make maps of itself
and so um one of my hypotheses is that
benoit mandelbrot that the
infinite that the infinite fractal zoom
is
as close of a approximation
as we can get to how the infinite
intelligence works
because you you said in your last couple
of sentences that there's a
a random number generator so there's
something that's absolutely chaotic
about it
but at the same time there's something
that's self-similar
and purposeful about it and so that's
what it seems like
is that you have both merged together
where you have the
it's like a chef if you viewed god or
the
supreme intelligence that we are as a
chef
we know both what tastes good in our
food
which is basically this uh you know this
two-eyed
you know four-limbed dna encoded vehicle
but also we want to taste new
qualities in our food and so we also
are randomly adding things into our
expressions creative expressions that we
then see how they
unfold how does that play with you
from what you've said it doesn't sound
like non-duality to me
it sounds like there's dualities all
over the place and
what i'm so like again have you ever
heard of
how the um
non-duality and duality and
individuation
are all simultaneously true have you
ever
heard that from a guest no no so this is
what we
call um true simultaneity
so there's the reason why you have
people like rupert
and um and many other people
that basically you know and you've heard
bernardo even say this on the show
before as well
but the only reason why he comes in with
the position of metaphysical idealism
is to like shift people towards that
but not to say that then physicalism is
untrue
because what you want to do is you want
to hold that both are true
simultaneously
consciousness is dependent on
physicalism just like physicalism is
dependent on consciousness
they're both dependent on one another
and so that's where you get the
simultaneity
where you have both non-duality and
duality
and individuation that all happen
simultaneously
are they both equal to one another or
are they just dependent on one another
it feels like they co-dependently
are part of the architecture
everything is co-dependently part of the
architecture
non-duality duality individuation is all
co-dependently
co-dependently part of the architecture
you'll never be able to get away with
having only one of them you have to
always be able to refer to all of them
at the same time
like that's what a jedi is a jedi is
somebody that can navigate into the
space of non-duality
have a conversation go to the space of
duality have a conversation
go to the space of individuation and
self-actualization
and have a conversation and that's what
i feel like you're doing
that's what i feel like i've been doing
is we've been training
like jedi's to become polymaths to be
able to navigate the space
like a jedi and then that's what sort of
gives you the most holistic
understanding
of what the nature is
okay let me get technical here is that
okay of course and then let's rap
because i know you have to go
soon right okay okay but i eminently i'm
enjoying this conversation i would like
to continue
me too bro okay i'm again
like i'm
so is the architecture more fundamental
than
the entities that are dependent on it
so you're saying there's duality
non-duality individuation and then
there's
the architecture that unites them in
some way shape or form so is this
architecture
the birthplace
potentially yes and also what makes the
environment um the birthplace and also
what sustains the substrate
of what this is yeah
okay
yeah or ground is another way to
potentially put it it's like a
groundless ground
is the architecture possible without the
flower that it sprouts
i feel like those have to codependently
um arise okay so then let me get
technical
to say so so architecture if
architecture then
duality if duality then architecture say
that one more time
if architecture then duality if duality
then architecture
say that another way i'm not sure okay
okay okay so
if there is the architecture then it's
necessary that there's duality
as well as non-duality let's just say
non-duality for this existence so if
there's the architecture then there's
non-duality
if non-duality exists then the
architecture exists is that a correct
statement or no
if you're co-dependent so you're
mentioning co-dependence co-dependency
yes
architecture great architecture is my
little lip
balm here so if this guy exists does
necessarily non-dualism exist
so if this does this necessarily exist
non-dual non-dualism is blue
architecture's green
oh i see which i think i see what you're
saying yeah well doesn't that also
kind of play into what we were saying a
moment ago with how
consciousness and physicalism are
ultimately one
well you were saying that yes uh yes i
understand because you can't have
you in a sense you can't have
consciousness without physicalism
and you can't have physicalism without
consciousness you can't have
a reality without observation
but you also can't have observation
without
reality so the two are one
yeah okay because then if that's true
then mathematically
one would say they're equivalent and
then because if you have an if-then
statement in both directions you have
what's called an if and only if
okay so then and that means they're
isomorphic okay now if they're
isomorphic that means you can replace
one with the other
and so why is one giving a
why is the prevailing place given to
non-dualism over dualism
or over the architecture and i feel like
this is this is exactly what i was
referencing with why
bernardo castro and why he and others
have said that they're not
they're not trying to um
they're just trying to help people shift
to become aware of the unity
um because they feel like by becoming
aware
of what he calls metaphysical idealism
by shifting into that position it
creates
more of a sense of unity and oneness
which then when you build
from that position you can actually
actualize the planet's potential
at a higher degree than if you were
building from the place of separation
and from the place of differentiation
only without having tasted the unity
and so it's almost like a temporary um
prioritization for the turn inward
in order to maximize the exterior
architectural potential
okay you're saying in order to so is
that goal
higher than the truth that apparently is
used to derive
the potential to execute on that goal so
for example
if non-dualism led to a place of
destruction for the earth would you
still advocate for non-dualism
hypothetically
now you may say logically that's
impossible but i'm saying hypothetically
and i'm sure
people can entertain what's logically
impossible so what would you do
[Applause]
if somehow they turn into laughing if
somehow to turn
into oneness created more uh planetary
catastrophe
than separation yeah well here's one way
it's not so it's not so out of left
field because
in some sense narcissism is self-love
and exaggerated self-love you
someone may say that that's not love at
all but then you're just quibbling over
what love is and no
that's not quibbling like that's a
serious serious issue
but it's not as if what love is is
trivial so let's say narcissism for the
sake of this argument is self-love
and overly so well if we're all
connected why is self-love not
not the same as loving this
loving everyone else if we're all the
same so if one has narcissism why is
that not a net
increment to society rather than a
decrement okay so
one can see how oneness can lead to a
destruction of the earth
potentially in a hypothetical universe
now i'm asking
if that is the case would you still
follow oneness or do you serve life
higher than that
like what's your god is your god oneness
or is your god humanity
well it's the simultaneity
that's which is what we were talking
about a moment ago where you can
hold both oneness and differentiation
at the same time and if you can do that
then you can have the most holistic
picture on how
infinity expresses itself which is what
you are
you're not separate from infinity
expressing itself
you are the same force that gave rise to
you
and so if you know that it's both
unified and differentiated
you can have the most holistic
perspective
and have the most
as you actualize yourself as you
firework yourself
you can have it be in the most
prosperous way for yourself in the
collective
because you come from the place of being
truly gnostic you know
gnosis means that you're
you have full knowledge of the nature in
your being
and so when you come from a gnostic
place you express yourself in the most
coherent most benevolent way it's
actually what lauza called wu
it's called effortless action it's
effortless
because you are a gnostic being because
you know the tao
you are the dao you are it and when
you're
it you don't commit malevolence
you purify your beingness to not
commit malevolence let me restate the
question because i'm not seeing
the answer in i'm not hearing how what
you say connects to the question
the question is if you could if the
choice was
if sorry if what came with oneness was
the destruction of the planet
would you still advocate for oneness
hypothetically i know you may say that's
impossible well even if you say that's
impossible then you're putting a limit
on an infant
infinite potential so you're saying some
some of what
is within this non-dual immaterial oh
that's a great point
architecture is that you can't put a
limit on the infinite potential
which means that there are civilizations
that potentially
emerge that get so turned into oneness
that somehow that turns into a
disastrous scenario
that's cool
yes okay so would you still advocate for
oneness if oneness would lead to the
to planetary destruction let's say
hypothetically the yeah the beauty of
the question is we just
we just went through one of those
explorations where
as infinity expresses itself are there
potentialities
where a civilization becomes overly
excessively oneness and unity oriented
to where it somehow blows itself up
based on that
and is that a possibility in infinite
potential
we're playing with infinite
possibilities so that could be
in fact happening right now and actually
to a certain extent isn't that what we
saw
with um the with the 20th century
we saw that with when you go overly
collectivist
and you don't have an equal amount of
individuation
and sovereignty with the individual
that's where you have the
disastrous um
tens of millions of deaths across the um
overly collectivist style of yeah yes
okay but now what it sounds like an
argument for pragmatism
rather than truth as in the objective
sense of truth or the corresponding
sense
because you're saying what we need is a
balance well how is that balance
we need a balance between non-dualism
and separation or dualism or plurality
why don't we keep calling it non-duality
and individuation
seems to be a good way to to put it for
sure
nonduality and individualization oneness
and individuation oh yes
yes okay well then what you say you use
the word extreme
now to use the word extreme already
implies a value now you've already
valued the wholeness of the
the oneness of the planet or the
thriving of people or the lessening of
suff the lessening of suffering and so
on
but that to me sounds pragmatic and not
not with respect to
the
what's true like i understand that in
pragmatism they have a different
definition of truth but if you're using
that definition of truth and that's
great
we need to know that but if you're using
if you're saying it's objectively true
like
like there's the correspondence theory
of truth there's something that's
outside me that these words are
somehow isomorphic too
then
right do you remember the story that you
gave
about your transpersonal experience
where you felt like
a tentacle of the cosmic octopus
so that is individuation in non-duality
so it's an absolute centerlessness
which is the big cosmic storm that we
are simultaneously
as it is that you are a unique
individual you're the unique tentacle
in that cosmic storm but you in order to
understand
that you are the cosmic storm you have
to in a sense perf you have to perforate
your skin so that you can burst outside
of the contracted identity of solely
being an individual
to also being the universe expressing
itself
as also cur simultaneously
right and like that's i would say that's
the one thing that oneness
goes really far to the extreme on and
individuation goes really far to the
extreme on
and if we can synthesize them into a
unity
that's where the la is
when you say that's something i'm
getting at that i wasn't able to express
before and forgive me if i'm loose with
my words
this is difficult for me to hold on to
right now
what i'm you're using the word extreme
no what makes you say
extreme it's there's a value embedded in
that then how do you get that value
where are you getting this value from to
say that something is extreme versus not
good well we have our at least our n of
one our own civilization
where we saw in the um
in the 20th century we saw that shift
into hyper
uh collectivism that turned very
disastrous
and we've also seen in the west we've
seen a um
an overly excessive focus on
individualism
as well and that um from at least our
end of one we see that there are
extremes
actually in better left unsaid your
documentary you explored one of those
extremes
right and so now you see where you have
where the extreme on the political um
right in the us and the extreme on the
political left in the us
have their own um disaster disastrous
codes and then if you can sort of if you
can gain a higher level awareness where
you can hold
both of those political sides
and sort of archive the codes that are
malevolent
and uplift the codes that are good
and merge them that's the same thing
with individualism and collectivism
non-duality and individuation um the
political left and political right in
the u.s
the us and china you can keep going with
these dichotomies
because what you want to do is you want
to take the best from two
and merge them into one rather than um
keep playing with the polar negatives on
each
on each one of them
and that's called what i call the
sorting algorithm
um that's from chapter
7 of high level perception the first
visual synthesis that i did
and actually i got the words sorting
algorithm
from brett weinstein when he was
moderating the debate between jordan
peterson and sam harris in vancouver
he said when they were talking about
science and spirituality
and how to merge the two brett said so
jordan you have a sorting algorithm of
sorts
and so that's where it was ding ding
ding ding ding that's what we're looking
for
how do you sort the good stuff of
non-duality
how do you sort the good stuff of
individualism or science and
spirituality or the us and china or the
left and the right
and how do you merge them that's what
yeah yeah
i allen what i'm wondering i know we got
to get going what i'm wondering is you
use the word good
there there's many you know there's much
language that's value-laden
and i'm wondering where are you getting
the value from that's what i'm wondering
so when you say extreme when you say
good
why is this good and this not and why is
this extreme and this not
that's basically what i'm wondering so
the one force
that we are undergoes a process of
figuring out
what is most good to bring
up so we have to go through our process
of sense making
right did you have daniel
schmuckenberger on yet
okay so he his thing is you know
communal sense making
and so we have to go through a process
of figuring out how to make
sense of what is good from these
um supposingly uh dual sides
and then to merge them into one so it's
not that atlas
or kurt or rupert or bernardo or whoever
has the answer
to what is good and everybody should
follow that leader
but it's more like a decentralized swarm
intelligence
that is the life force that we are
figures out what is good
and then ends up
fireworking that
we're gonna have to cut this
conversation short man we'll continue
later
yeah that's so good wow thank you so
much man
wow yeah so i feel by the way what made
you
how did you find out about the channel
and what made you reach out to me
or i may have reached out to you
actually actually remember
in i think it was in the middle of 2020
that's when you started the channel
right yep
okay it's about a year ago i was
so happy that you existed and i still am
i'm so happy because
there was there was basically
there was nobody that was doing it yet
and then you filled the spot
because nobody was doing it nobody was
interviewing these greatest minds
and then trying to figure out a
landscape of the theories of everything
and as soon as i saw your channel go up
i was just
so pumped and so uh jacked
and and and then and then you did
what most people can't well most people
can't do
which is not only did you come up with
the idea it came through you to do this
but then furthermore is you did it for a
year
and you've grown such a tremendous
catalog of content and a tremendous
um free educational library around this
and then so you've provided this great
resource for people
and you've created somewhat of a
monetization stability for yourself
to ensure that you can independently
continue doing
what you're passionate about and so i'm
so jacked but of course take the two
weeks of time just to rejuvenate
yourself my brother
give your heart and your mind and your
gut and your wife and
your just give yourself the space to
just relax into the profundity of who
you are and what you've achieved
you know congratulate yourself for that
period of a couple weeks
and then you know get back to it
how do you how long have you been doing
this for
i know that you're yours is also
extremely personal sorry in person
it started out as events as far as i
know yeah how long has that been going
on how long has the podcast been going
on
what's your goal with it in 2015
i initially started asking people on the
streets
thought-provoking questions so about six
years ago
and then i and then i and then i
transitioned to hosting a science comedy
show
in san francisco and then i transitioned
to hosting simulation
in 2017 which is where i was just asking
these greatest minds these stop
provoking questions
to do that congrats man you're like
thanks before at that time exactly 24
yep
yep bro yep and and that but that's i
feel like that
14 year olds and 18 year olds to begin
asking these big questions at those
teenage years
and um in doing so they can
rocket themselves forward at
unprecedented rates
yeah yeah you know i've been so i had
got to get going i've been surprised
that
most of my audience is actually not
young i mean there are quite a few young
people but
most of them are they're far older than
you would think they're
somewhat 60 70 some are professors
oh man yes yes did i receive an email
from a professor and or multiple it's
like a
huge huge compliment because those are
the most those are the toughest crowds
and like i used to do stand-up and there
are some crowds that are tough well
with in this space a professor is a
tough crowd
okay okay well we have a lot of love
from our audience
and we love you guys thank you so much
we're so grateful
um you guys are coming from both of our
our channels and we're so so grateful
that you love this and that
we're going to come back i feel like
kurt and i hopefully once every like
quarter or something
will come with one another yeah exactly
and thank you everyone and infinite love
for you let us know how you feel about
the episode in the comments below we
would love to hear from you
that simultaneity around non-duality and
individuation and dualism all this type
of stuff
and um also like the video
and help that youtube algorithm also
check out the links in the
bio to subscribing to kurt's channel
also you can find his recent documentary
better left unsaid down there as well
and subscribe to our channel simulation
if you haven't yet shared this video on
theories of everything where we have
this conversation
with other people that you feel like
this would profoundly resonate with
and that is all we love you fam
anything else kurt yeah
what i'm trying to build with theories
of everything is both
i don't want to use the word 2.0 it's so
old now but something like science 2.0
or science 3.0
think about this science progressed it
wasn't science before and then it became
this now
which means that
you can wonder just a thought experiment
what will it be
and what are the what's the criteria for
what makes something science science
and partly what what i'm doing with
theories of everything is not only
advancing
the state of theories of everything by
explicating tells
but also what does the next science look
like i call it
i have a couple of name names for it one
is
it can't pronounce it but of genosis and
the reason why is because
adjena means knowledge into the eastern
end this is
a specific kind of knowledge and the
gnosis obviously means knowledge to the
west
and i imagine that there's going to be
an integration of the two
i also imagine that there's going to be
a third i don't see why there's just a
dichotomy
maybe there's one that we haven't come
up with we think experience is primary
now
but maybe 100 years from now it's it's
beyond its transcended experience and
rationality it's something else i don't
know
it sounds i i don't know
but either way i'm trying to build that
with the channel i also have a discord
on the channel
i mean for the channel for this
so join the chicota theories i've ever
searched theories of everything on
youtube you'll see it looks like a
apparently it looks like a reese's
peanut butter cup logo
the link is in the bio below and also
joined
are you vegan am i vegan
oh um no no but i'm not especially
carnivorous either but i i don't yeah i
don't have a food
um no i i eat whatever
most of the time i don't like fish i
don't like seafood but i
accept salmon i like salmon by the way
we had another
remember i messaged you this brando from
our channel said hope we have an episode
with frank yang i think kurt can make
amazing interview with him
remember i messaged you and said that it
could be good for you to have frank yang
and uh bentino masaro on the show for
theories of everything so that's
something to also consider
i will message you about it again we'll
talk about it again right after this
okay love you guys i'm going to end the
broadcast we'll stay in the studio for
just a minute
we'll talk to you guys soon again thank
you so much thank you